the Joe Rogan experience when you think
about these social media sites gab was
one where this guy who shot up the Tree
of Life that was a member of and is is
this like I'm not a I'm clearly not a
proponent of censorship but do people do
you think they get radicalized in these
when you get to a forum where there's no
restrictions whatsoever on language or
ideology or behavior you could say
whatever you want as long as it's long
as you're not saying something you don't
I mean gab has rules like you can't do
things that are illegal you can't
threaten someone you can't put up their
address you can't but you could say a
lot of really [ __ ] up [ __ ] and they're
not gonna they're not gonna police you
do you think that these places that do
allow free speech that there's a
catch-22 to it in some ways it's great
to be able to express yourself freely
but in other ways you can get
radicalized and they can they can it can
lead to a lot of people forming these
groups where they support each other in
these [ __ ] up ideas yeah I'll see two
things one of the reasons that I feel so
strongly about keeping the spectrum of
acceptable opinions so like as wide as
possible is because I think that the
narrower it shrinks like we're talking
about normal ideas being closeted then
people go into these underground layers
online and they become radicalized right
because they're like that you know the
elites are in the mainstream media or
whoever they're not telling the truth
they're lying to me so there's this
secret world and this secret world has
all of these actually bigoted ideas
sooner and I mean yes so do I think that
it is a catch-22 yeah yes I mean the
whole thing about the world we're living
in
is that you no longer have to like find
a KKK meeting you don't have to find a
jihadist preacher you don't have to
fight you know go down the line you just
have to find a reddit chat or a 4chan
chat or something on Gabe comm and you
find your little online village like it
no longer requires a real purse
a real interaction right and there's no
stakes because there's no shame because
you can just be totally anonymous in
these forums right so I just like I I
think that social media is supercharging
this in a way that like we can't even
grasp and it's very hard for those of us
like me and you who want to protect free
speech and Liberty to think about how to
deal with it you're right how do you
deal with that like when you have
someone like the Christchurch shooter
who was live-streaming this and making
references to you know what what did
what do you think he referenced the tree
of life she reference PewDiePie as well
like yeah he was it's like all in
elaborate troll that's what's crazy it's
like he's [ __ ] posting and murdering at
the same time and what is the I mean
there's no in my eyes there's no clear
solution to that I don't want to
restrict free speech I certainly don't
want you don't understand honest people
you also don't want someone to be free -
yes live stream killing people on a
platform right but how could you I mean
they're they're managing at scale how
could you possibly know when someone's
live streaming that they're about to go
and kill people right when the guys
never killed anybody before and then all
of a sudden he's got this camera on and
he walks in the synagogue and he starts
shooting no that's right with him it was
two mosques he killed like 52 people
yeah I mean it's all insane what how do
you how do we manage that I mean what
what do we do what do we do and that's
certainly there's no in my mind there's
no clear answer here there's not a clear
answer but I think that look the idea
that a private company should be
obligated to stream someone killing
someone or let's even go like take it
less stakes than that call Jews [ __ ]
why should why should a private company
say yes to that it's degrading what the
platform is right yeah that makes sense
that makes sense the question is where
does that line get drawn I know you know
this is this is the real problem I mean
there's people that get kicked off of
certain social media sites for
just not representing well culturally
for instance Megan Marco knows I don't
know what is her name Mary Murphy Megan
Murphy that woman who got kicked off of
Twitter because she said a man is never
a woman and she got kicked off for life
totally but this is what I mean about
when reasonable opinions when the
spectrum of what is reasonable becomes
so narrow people radicalize yes and they
go to these bigoted ideas yes and it's
an enormous like it's like why do we
need a healthy conversation about
immigration and like in the the
conversation about immigration is I
think very very limited in what people
say and you know what they what is
acceptable like it's like open borders
or xenophobia right you know and there
has to be kind of reasonable middle and
way to talk about it yeah because if not
people self radicalized that's just I
just see that happening again and again
and again on so many different topics
yeah the immigration angle is a perfect
example that I mean should be absolutely
possible for hard-working people to make
it to America and do better it also
should be possible for us to keep gang
members and cartel members from crossing
the border freely and shooting people
and killing people and selling drugs in
our communities and all the things that
we're scared of when it comes to the
open border policy idea the the thing
about the the social media thing in in a
lot of ways it's this new experiment
right it's something that we've never
had before like if you like you're
saying about a KKK meeting you used to
have to go to one mm hang right and now
you don't don't just have to go to
Stormfront or wherever you know whatever
website you can find that supports your
ideas and this is this is a new
challenge and there's a new challenge
that hasn't really been mapped out nor
has it been I don't know if it's been
rationally dissected in terms of like if
we do this this could happen if we don't
do this this could happen which is is a
or b better what how do we stop a or or
B from happening how do we somehow or
another educate and improve how do we
reach out to a lot of these people that
are going to get radicalized and offer
them some sort of a positive community
as
as a possible alternative because this
is what a lot of this stuff is a lot of
these people that get radicalized one
thing that happens is you don't have
anyone that cares about you or supports
you but you find people that are very
strongly believe in an idea they believe
in an idea an awful idea so much so that
they're willing to kill people for that
idea and then you find a bunch of them
and then they reinforce each other's
beliefs totally with these positive
affirmations and and they're essentially
they're signaling to them they're
virtually signaling to these horrible
people that they also agree with a lot
of these ideas and then you go out and
you do something you act like the guy in
Charlottesville that ran over that girl
this these these horrific acts are
almost there encouraged and supported by
these tight-knit groups of people that
all they're all they're all [ __ ] up
and [ __ ] up people find each other and
hurt people hurt people right so they
find this category of people is this
group of people whether it's online or
whether they actually have to go to a
KKK meaning and they find support this
is a group that somehow or another gets
them
[Applause]